Sometimes people think of
a large language model
as a knowledge store, as if it's
learned to memorize a
lot of information, maybe
off the internet, so
when you ask it a question, it
can answer the question.
But I think a even more useful way
to think of a
large language model is
sometimes as a reasoning engine,
in which you can give it chunks of
text or other sources
of information.
And then the large language model,
LLM, will maybe use
this background knowledge that's
learned off the internet, but
to use the new
information you give it
to help you answer
questions or reason through
content or decide even
what to do next. And that's what
LangChain's Agents framework
helps you to do.
Agents are probably my
favorite part of LangChain.
I think they're
also one of the most powerful parts, but
they're also
one of the newer parts. So we're
seeing a lot of stuff emerge
here that's really new to
everyone in the field. And so this should
be a very exciting lesson
as we dive into what
agents are, how to create and
how to use agents, how to equip them
with different types of
tools, like search engines that
come built into LangChain,
and then also how
to create your own
tools, so that you can
let agents interact with any
data stores, any APIs, any
functions that you
might want them to.
So this is exciting, cutting-edge
stuff, but
already with emerging, important
use cases. So with that, let's
dive in!
So to get started with Agents, we're
going to start as we always do, by
importing the correct
environment variables.
We're also going to need to
install a few packages here. So
we're going to use the "duckduckgo-search" engine
and "wikipedia". So we're
going to want
to pip install those. I've already installed those
in my environment, so I'm not going
to run this
line. But if you guys have not,
you should uncomment that line, run
it, and then you're good
to go.
We're then going to import
some methods and classes
that we need from LangChain. So
we're going to import some methods
to load tools.
And these are things that we're
going to connect the
language model to. We're going
to load a method to
initialize the agent. We're going to
load the Chat OpenAI
wrapper, and we're going to load
"AgentType".
So "AgentType"
will be used to specify what
type of agent we want to use.
There are a bunch of different
types of agents in LangChain. We're
not going to go over
all of them right now. We'll just
choose one and run with that. We're then
going to initialize the language model
that we're going to use.
Again, we're using this as the
reasoning engine that we're
using to drive the agent.
We'll then load the tools that we're going
to use.
So we're going to load DuckDuckGo
search and Wikipedia. And
these are built-in LangChain
tools. Finally, we're going to
initialize the agent.
We pass it the tools,
the language model, and agent type.
And so here we're using "CHAT_ZERO_SHOT_REACT_DESCRIPTION".
Not going to go over in
too much detail what this means.
The important things to note are chat.
This is optimized to
work with chat models.
And then react. React is a
prompting strategy that
elicits better thoughts
from a language model.
We're also going to set "handle_parsing_errors=True".
If you remember from the first lesson,
we chatted a bunch
about output parsers and
how those can be used to take the
LLM output, which is a string,
and parse it into
a specific format that
we can use downstream.
That's extremely important here. When
we take the output of the LLM, which
is text, and parse it into
the specific action and the specific
action input that
the language model should take.
Let's now use this agent. Let's ask
it a question about a recent
event that the model, when it
was trained, didn't know. So let's ask
it about
the 2022 World Cup.
The models here were trained
on data up to around 2021.
So it shouldn't
know the answer to this question. And
so it should realize that
it needs to use a
tool to look up this
recent piece of information.
So we can see here that the agent
realizes that it needs
to use DuckDuckGo search,
and then looks up
the 2022 World Cup winner.
And so it gets back a bunch of
information. We can then see
that the agent thinks
that the 2022 World
Cup has not happened yet.
So this is a good example of why
agents are still pretty exploratory.
You can see that there's
a bunch of information here
about the 2022 World Cup, but
it doesn't quite
realize all that has happened. And so
it needs to look up more things and
get more information. And so
then based on that information, it can
respond with the correct
answer that "Argentina won
the 2022 World Cup".
Let's then ask it a
question where it should
recognize that it needs
to use Wikipedia.
So Wikipedia, it has a lot
of information about specific
people and specific entities
from a long time ago. It doesn't
need to be current information.
So let's ask it about Tom M. Mitchell,
an
American computer scientist. And
what book did he write? We
can see here that
it recognizes that it
should use Wikipedia to
look up the answer. So
it searches for Tom M. Mitchell
Wikipedia.
And then does another follow-up
search just to make sure that it's got
the right answer. So it
searches for "Tom M. Mitchell Machine
Learning" and gets
back more information.
And then based on that, it's
able to finally answer with "Tom M. Mitchell
wrote the textbook, 'Machine
Learning'".
You should pause the
video here and try
putting in different inputs.
So far, we've used tools that come
defined in LangChain already, but
a big power of agents is that you
can connect it to
your own sources of information, your
own APIs, your own data.
So here we're going to go over
how you can create
a custom tool so
that you can connect
it to whatever you want.
Let's make a tool that's going
to tell us what the
current data is.
First, we're
going to import this tool decorator.
This can be applied
to any function and
it turns it into
a tool that LangChain can use. Next,
we're
going to write a function called "time",
which takes in any text string. We're
not really going to use that. And it's
going to return today's date by calling
date time.
In addition to the name of the function,
we're also going to write a
really detailed doc string.
That's because this is what
the agent will use
to know when it
should call this tool and how it should
call this tool.
For example, here we say that,
"The input should always
be an empty string.". That's
because we don't use it.
If we have more
stringent requirements on what
the input should be, for example,
if we have a
function that should always
take in a search query or a SQL
statement, you'll want to make sure
to mention that here. We're now
going to create another agent. This time
we're adding the
time tool to the list
of existing tools.
And finally, let's
call the agent and ask it
what the date today is.
It recognizes that it needs
to use the time tool,
which it specifies here.
It has the action input as an empty
string. This is great.
This is what we told it to do.
And then it returns with an observation.
And then finally,
the language model
takes that observation
and responds to the user, "Today's
date is 2023-05-21".
You should pause the
video here and try
putting in different inputs.
This wraps up the lesson on agents.
This is one of the newer
and more exciting
and more experimental
pieces of LangChain.
So I hope you enjoy using it.
Hopefully it showed you how you
can use a language model as
a reasoning engine
to take different
actions and connect
to other functions and data sources.